welcome to the program we begin with
breaking news coming out of south africa
where the nobel peace prize winner
archbishop desmond tutu has died
appointed the first black archbishop of
cape town tutu rose to prominence in the
1980s as a vocal opponent of apartheid
he was 90 years old let's go to our
correspondent for media miller who's
following events for us in johannesburg
and joins me on the phone uh for me to
along with nelson mandela he really was
south africa's moral compass through
very dark times
that's certainly the case and as we
listen to trippy's coming in this
morning shortly um
after his death we hear from people who
talk about a man who was led by his
conscience irrespective of the topic at
hand he was somebody who was even
critical of the existing political
leadership one that he fought for during
the days of apartheid his belief was
always centered around justice around
what the rights of people and what was
important to south africans and i just
quickly want to read one line from the
tribute from the presidency saying that
desmond tusa was a patriot without equal
a leader of principle and pragmatism who
gave meaning to the biblical insight
that faith without works is dead
he stood his ground didn't he for me he
wasn't afraid to eyeball his adverse
adversaries over a career that was what
decades in the making
not at all and he saw this especially
during his fight during apartheid
against apartheid his time abroad when
he was in the uk as well as when he got
into south africa when he shared the
truth and reconciliation commission um
in the early 90s and that was just after
apartheid was dismantled where he wanted
answers from people he wanted to hold
people accountable for the atrocities
that had occurred and those were also
scenes where we saw the um archbishop
break down in tears
devastated by some of the testimony that
he had heard but he continued as i say
to be a man of conscience in dealing
with the ongoing social and racial
issues in south africa irrespective of
the opponent he was facing and this is
where you might say he gained global
respect because wherever he went across
the african continent and set definitely
to europe asia and the americas people
wanted to listen to him they wanted to
hear his point of view because what he
said resonated at that time in that
place in that country
and that's absolutely the case and even
when you hear from people who interacted
with him they say it was with great
sincerity he was a man without any ears
and graces and and
very much you can't separate the
archbishop from his
christian beliefs and what he thought
was correct um and also what was key in
terms of the role that he played in this
country when there were political
uh people like nelson mandela
who were imprisoned at the time he kept
the fires burning he kept the fires
burning in terms of that fight against
apartheid and and that is the kind of
message that was respected and then also
sticking to his principles
essentially but just really it's
humility and sincerity that always want
people over
for me to we'll leave it there for now
of course continue to follow the
tributes that come in with you from
south africa you're in johannesburg
thanks very much
joe nahul looks back now at desmond
tutu's life
this is desmond tutu hearing the news
that nelson mandela would soon be
released
he was seldom one to contain his
feelings it just triggered me off
this tutus response as head of south
africa's truth and reconciliation
commission on hearing details of
atrocities committed by both sides if
apartheid is not dismantled
was born in a mining town outside
johannesburg at a time of strict
segregation
things would get much worse as he grew
up
tutu was 17 when the national party came
to power in 1948 racial inequality
became law
apartheid
he'd wanted to be a doctor but became a
teacher instead witnessing first-hand
the government's policy of depriving
black south africans of education
consigning them to servitude
and the protests that followed
like the sharpville massacre in 1960 69
people were killed and most of them were
shot in the back as they were running
away protesting against the past laws i
remember it as a moment when
you realized
that black life was
cheap
[Music]
tutu must have thought he could do more
in the church he joined the clergy
eventually obtaining high anglican
office as dean of johannesburg and later
archbishop of cape town
it propelled him into the public eye as
an unflinching moral voice
why our struggle is going to succeed
is not
just because
of numbers
our struggle is going to succeed because
it is a just struggle
by 1984 desmond tutu had won global
admiration he was awarded the nobel
peace prize
it was the kind of recognition that
south africa's anti-apartheid movement
needed to become a global force for a
very very long time i i did hope
that the world would would hear our plea
and that is why we
urge the world to apply sanctions
archbishop desmond tutu was one of the
world's foremost human rights
campaigners an active member of the
elders in the cause of world peace
remembered as much for his unremitting
optimism and infectious laugh
when he introduced nelson mandela as
south africa's new president in 1994
tutu recalled that he whispered to god
if i die now it would be almost the
perfect moment someone up there
must really have been on our side of
operating for us
when mandela died many worried that
south africa had lost its moral compass
they may now wonder whether it's lost
its guiding light
trevor phillips is a british
anti-apartheid campaigner and chair of
the equality and human rights commission
joins me now from london good morning mr
phillips i know that you knew the
archbishop very well i can only begin to
imagine the memories and the
conversations that will be swirling
around in your head right now when you
think back at the man that we've lost
good morning sahel yes um
i in fact knew him
rather more as a person if i can put it
that way than the public figure
because his son
who's also called trevor
and i
were
contemporaries at university and we've
been friends for
now gosh half a century
um
but i think obviously the important
thing for
most of the world actually right now is
the loss of what i think your
correspondent correctly
described as this
towering moral
figure um i think
the important
uh issue thing to remember about him is
that
during the
uh
last days or the end of the apartheid
era
many of the people who
fought that battle
were either out of the country or they
were in jail
he had a unique freedom
which most people
would probably not have exercised in
quite the
uh the the the extraordinary way that he
did um he was able to speak out he was
able to
draw attention to the awful uh
characteristics of that system
um because to some extent he was
protected
but the fact that he was protected by
the dog collar if i can put it that way
doesn't shouldn't lessen our regard for
his courage because
all sorts of people suffered during that
period indeed he he would go he would he
would be under house arrest he would go
in and out of south africa he would have
his passport removed and confiscated by
uh pickboat who was a prime minister of
south africa at the top president of
south africa at the time you know we
tend to think as you say you can't be
protected by the dog collar but you know
he wasn't afraid of eyeballing his
adversaries and i think that's why
perhaps many across the world will
pay tribute to him for that strength of
character and a strength of character
that he got from black south africans
and other apar anti-apartheid leaders
yes and i think
we often forget with these um
great figures that they have lives too
um i i look at this as i say to some
extent through
um the eyes of
one whose children's friends and
it's worth saying
that for him
uh that courage wasn't just a matter of
a sort of personal courage but it was he
knew that there would be a price to pay
for him he himself but also for
every member of his family
and he
persuaded them brought them along
enfolded them
and as far as he could stood in front of
them and that's
but i think
you know we forget that for him he knew
that
those close to him were also paying a
price and that in many ways i suspect
would be more
would have been
more of a
heartbreak more of a more painful for
him than anything that might have
happened to him but still
he saw the the greater need the bigger
cause and fought it
frankly to to today because let's
remember he hasn't been particularly
sparing
in his criticism of the current
post-apartheid government as well and
that's what i mean when i say this
moral character always shone through
indeed and yet to i see you've given us
a sense of how you might say uh uh
decent a chap he was and uh where he
stood when it came to family and
professional duty so finally mr phillips
i've got to ask you when you when we
talk about global greats such as
martin luther king gandhi mandela he
would modestly most probably say i don't
want to be in that list but do you think
he is up there in that list
oh yes oh yes he he's it up there in
that celestial choir and i suspect that
we will at some point um
when we join him we'll be hearing that
infectious laugh and he will be leading
the conga and he will be telling jones
and
it's worth saying this is the guy who
brought humanity to politics he brought
the common touch not that easy even
to see even amongst these great moral
figures this this was a man
that you knew you could spend an
afternoon or an evening with and you
would no doubt deal with the large
issues but you'd go away happy and
laughing
so let's not
forget this was a great human being as
well and i'm sure that's how it'll be
remembered trevor phillips there joining
us from london thanks so much for
joining us and thanks for your time